[Musique]
cette semaine du handicap est organisée
dans tous les ans pour sensibiliser les
personnes
ou handicap voir un peu les difficultés
que les personnes rencontrent avec des
animations comme des jeux des du sport
et nous ciblons essentiellement les
enfants
[Musique]
il y aura dans les écoles traumatinées
dans les écoles maternelles un compte en
langue des signes ensuite il y a
l'association Capsa qui intervient aussi
avec les collèges et les primaires et
ensuite nous avons le sport adapté qui
est avec handisport le mercredi
après-midi
[Musique]
il y a une conférence équilibrée
audition qui est animée mardi soir à
19h30 avec l'audio prothésiste Thomas
Moueix et Antoine Ravinet qui a un
kinésithérapeute on a le samedi matin un
atelier autiste bien comprendre
qui se passe à l'Agora et le samedi soir
il y a le théâtre le tiroir à bonheur
qui est proposé par l'association second
souffle
[Musique]